Palestinians have welcomed a United
Nations report on companies with
business ties to illegal Israeli
settlements in the occupied West Bank
the UN says it's identified 112 business
entities including the us-based
home renting company Airbnb Israel has
described this as shameful we're gonna
take this story on now we can speak to
Omar Amidala who's from the Palestinian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs joins us
live from Ramallah welcome to program
say it just tell us first of all more
about your reactions in this news
actually we will come this long-awaited
database of companies that are working
directly or indirectly with the illegal
settlements we see that we see it as
positive development toward
accountability and respect for the human
rights of the Palestinian people and the
Cuban decision territory this is how we
see it now Israel of course of denounces
they say it's a shameful capitulation to
pressure from countries and businesses
intent on hurting Israel what do you
make of that actually this shameful is
still there are some companies are
profiting from the this illegal
settlements using our resources because
the settlements are illegal under
international law and I do believe that
what is shameful that these companies
are still working with these illegal
Israeli settlements tell us more about
what impact these businesses have for
Palestinian businesses I do believe that
that when we have when we had the the
fact-finding mission on the
ramifications of the illegal Israeli
settlements on social and economical
rights of the Palestinian people they
came up with this decision that the
guiding principles of business and the
human rights they should take action
these businesses are violating the the
international law violating the right of
the Palestinian people to economic and
social development because these
businesses are built on our occupied
land on the land of the Palestinian
people so we believe it is time for
these businesses to stop to quit
perfect earring or there will be
consequences and legal consequences and
do these businesses directly impact the
Palestinian economy definitely because
this this these companies are working on
an occupied land they are using our
resources so they have no taxes there is
a policy of encouragement for these
businesses in the occupied Palestinian
territory so our companies our our
workers they have a less treatment
according to the work with these with
these companies and the Brazilian
economics actually according to um tad
reports it says that there is a lot of
damage for the Palestinian economy
because of the illegal Israeli
settlements and because of the illegal
Israeli occupation in Palestine right
Airbnb was one of the ones we mentioned
it's also booking.com Expedia
TripAdvisor also talked to say this
report released by the United Nations
they also issued a statement which said
that while the settlements as such are
regarded as illegal under international
law this report does not provide a legal
characterization of the activities in
question or of business enterprises
involvement in them what do you make of
that I do believe that one one and one
hundred twelve companies that are
working and these illegal illegal
settlements will bear will be illegal
consequences if they are not going to
quit and working in these illegal
illegal settlements we do believe that
the ruling of the the the court of
justice the European Court of Justice in
last September is very clear about the
illegality of the products of the the
Israeli settlements we think that maybe
this report is not a legal report it's a
list of companies we need to work with
with the office of High Commissioner the
High Commissioner because she has to to
update this list annually we need to
work with the states with countries
toward their responsibilities and to
hold and assume their responsibilities
to
to talk to these companies telling them
that what they are doing is illegal we
do believe that we need to put a
resolution at one stage to call for this
companies to the draw from from the
illegal alien settlements in this way
they will be illegal consequence over
these companies all right we'll leave it
there our dollar from the Palestinian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs thank you
thank you